بالفعل في دان انا اتواجد الان في قلب
العاصمه في هذه الاثناء همم تنطلق
المضادات الجويه في اكثر من مكان ونحن
ننتظر هذا الهواء استمعنا بشكل واضح هنا
في المحيط في قلب العاصمه الى اكثر من سته
انفجارات واحد من هذه الانفجارات انطلق من
تلك الجهه من خلفي وهي المنطقه التي
يتواجد فيها القصر الرئاسي وشاهدنا اعمده
الدخان في السماء نتيجه المضادات الجويه
الصادره عن الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه في
هذه الاثناء الاداره العسكريه في كيف تؤكد
بتجدد القصف الروسي على العاصمه ومنطقه
العاصمه وضواحي العاصمه وتقول بان هنالك
اسقاط لعدد من الصواريخ الروسيه التي
انطلقت من البحر الاسود ومن بحر قزوين ليس
كياب واحده التي اعلن فيها حاله التاهب
الجو قبل نصف ساعه من الان وانما عديد
المقاطعات في هذه الاثناء المحال الكبيره
في العاصمه اخليت بالكامل هنالك حركه
الناس نحاول ان نقرب لكم الصوره في هذه
الاثناء كما تشاهدون حركه المركبات اا
تمضي بشكل طبيعي الناس في الميدان الرئيسي
هنا في ميدان الاستقلال حيث اقف بالاضافه
الى تلك المنطقه التي يستطيع ان يقربها
لكم الزميل المصور وهي منطقه القصر
الرئاسي منطقه القصر الرئاسي قبل دقيقه من
الان كنا نرصد فيها عدد من اصوات
الانفجارات وهي بالتاكيد ناتجه عن
المضادات الجويه الاوكرانيه ورصدنا ايضا
دخانا متصاعدا في السماء في تلك المنطقه
وجدد مره اخرى واقول بانها منطقه القصر
الرئاسي في قلب العاصمه كياب حاله الانذار
الجوي اعلنت هنا في قلب العاصمه قبل نصف
ساعه من الان
سلطات المحليه عمده كياب الاداره العسكريه
هنا في العاصمه دعت السكان الى البقاء في
الملاجئ لكن هذه الحركه التي تشاهدونها في
الشوارع وفي الميادين الرئيسيه في كيا هي
حركه اعتياديه الناس هنا نهايه همم
تاقلموا وتعايشوا مع القصف المتكرر نعم